ça te fait quoi de rencontre et en
double parfois très mauvais effet et toi
le matin quand tu es devant la glace
comment tu te trouves j'évite de me
regarder dans la glace le matin mais
alors vraiment
pas t'aurais aimé ressembler à qui quand
tu étais petit
alain delon tiens tiens pourquoi pas à
moi quand j'étais petit je te pas
terrible avant tu changerais quoi si tu
avais une baguette magique en toi ma
hauteur je trouve que c'est un peu court
sur pattes
qu'est ce que tu as de plus sexy en toi
donc à bout intéressant est ce que tu
m'as borderais si tu me rencontrer non
tu m'aimes pas tous les jours quelle est
l'insulté qui t'a fait le plus mal
[ __ ]
quand as-tu pleurer pour la dernière
fois avant-hier tu es content de ta vie
jusqu'à aujourd'hui c'est un débat dans
lequel je ne veux pas rentrer ce soir
qu'est ce que tu écris lorsqu'on te
demande un autographe
si c'est une femme j'écris tendresse si
c'est un garçon j'écris amitié hervé
vilard et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de 1h10 tube abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus